النقاشات داخل قاعه مجلس المحافظين هنا
حول ايران طغت عليها المخاوف من اثار
اليورانيوم العاليه التخصيب التي عثر
عليها مفتشون تابعون للوكاله في منشاه
فوردو الايرانيه والتي بلغت تقريبا
84% ولكن الدبلوماسيين الغربيين هنا
يقولون انهم يتمهلون بالتصعيد لاعطاء
ايران فرصه لشرح اسباب العثور على اثار
اليورانيوم العالي التخصيب هذا
الدبلوماسيون او الدول الاوروبيه حذرت حتى
ايران من ان عدم اعطاء جواب لامين عام
الوكاله الدوليه رافاييل جروستي كما وعدت
وبشكل سريع سيعرضها للمحاسبه وقالت بان
الرد الذي اعطته حتى الان غير مقنعه
اسابيع قليله ستظهر ما اذا كانت ايران
ستفي بتعهداتها التي اطلقتها على رافايا
الجروس امين عام الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه
الذريه هنا ام انها تماطل من جديد وهكذا
مماطله ستدفع بالدول الغربيه للدعوه
الاجتماع طارق لمجلس المحافظين كما اكد
لنا دبلوماسيون حتى قبل اجتماع المجلس
الدوري في يونيو المقبل وطرح مشروع قرار
جديد يدين ايران يكون الثالث خلال عام
واحد راغده برنامج العربيه فيينا